la segunda enmienda de la constitución
de eeuu protege el derecho de los
ciudadanos a poseer y llevar armas sin
embargo tras doscientos tiroteos masivos
sólo en 2022 la pregunta persiste porque
ningún presidente estadounidense ha
logrado una reforma armamentística en
décadas según la legislación de eeuu
este tipo de reforma requiere una
mayoría de casi dos tercios 60 sobre 100
votos en el senado una aritmética
complicada hasta el momento los intentos
de los demócratas de reformar el control
de armas se han encontrado con múltiples
dificultades sobre todo por parte de la
oposición republicana muy vinculada al
poderoso lobby de las armas que quiere
impedir cualquier cambio significativo
en 1994 el presidente clinton logró la
prohibición de armas de asalto durante
10 años
earl watson armas militares armas de
guerra nunca estuvieron pensadas para un
día en el campo están pensadas para una
noche en las calles on line on the
streets en parte debido a vacíos legales
la norma no impidió nuevos tiroteos
masivos cinco años más tarde la matanza
en la escuela de columbine reavivó pero
un congreso controlado por el partido
republicano bloqueó cualquier
endurecimiento del control de armas tras
la masacre de sandy hook en 2012 el
presidente obama propuso varias medidas
para limitar la circulación de armas de
fuego y con un senado de mayoría
demócrata parecía posible pero a falta
de seis apoyos republicanos no se aprobó
la reforma
hace unos minutos una minoría en el
senado decidió que no valía la pena
bloquearon reformas armamentísticas que
son de sentido común incluso mientras
estas familias observaban desde la
galería del senado los arg a la
administración trump consideraba las
armas un pilar crucial de la defensa de
la constitución aunque se perpetraron
algunas de las peores matanzas de la
historia del país durante el mandato del
ex presidente el joe wright del agua
como su presidente nunca voy a vulnerar
el derecho de la gente a tener y llevar
armas
este miércoles el presidente baiden dijo
que era el momento de convertir el dolor
en acción pero para el cambio necesita
conseguir la mayoría de 60 votos en el
senado los demócratas tienen una mayoría
muy estrecha y podrían perder aún más
terreno tras las elecciones de medio
término de noviembre